foreign
[Music]
for Monday February 13th I'm Zoe Thomas
for The Wall Street Journal
Facebook parent meta has been having
trouble getting users on to its
metaverse its platform called Horizon
worlds had fewer than 200 000 monthly
active users this past October according
to internal documents reported on by The
Wall Street Journal last fall but the
company is revamping its strategy
according to a memo sent to the team
working on the initiative reviewed by
the Journal it's going after younger
users joining us to discuss this
approach and how meta plans to attract
teens and young adults is our social
media reporter Salvador Rodriguez hi Sal
welcome back to the show Hey Zoe thanks
for having me again let's so how does
meta plan to attract more young users
yeah so what they're going to be doing
this year as opposed to last year is in
2022 there was a big emphasis on having
the users of horizon themselves go in
and make worlds that populated this
metaverse for the company what we're
seeing in their new strategy that was
outlined recently is that they want a
greater emphasis placed on experiences
and worlds built by second party Studios
so really what they want is they want
worlds built out by people that are
closer to video game designers as
opposed to Everyday Horizon users and
we've already seen some of this in the
time that Horizon has existed the most
notable example is this world that was
built in partnership with the NBA called
NBA arena so if you're a horizon user
you should expect to see more of these
professional-like worlds populate
Horizon in the coming months we're
talking about meta wanting to attract
younger users to Horizon Worlds how
young are we talking yeah So the plan is
to open up the service to teenagers ages
13 to 17 so that would essentially
expand from what's available now which
is 18 and up and the reasoning behind
this is that these are the generations
of users that have grown up with the
internet throughout their entire lives
they're used to interacting with others
remotely especially after living through
this pandemic and not only that but
these are the users who you know have
the free time to enjoy the metaverse but
also they are so young that if you get
them on this service early this is a
user that you will have probably for a
long time can you tell us a little bit
more about your sourcing how do you know
this yeah so this sourcing came from
people familiar with the matter as well
as a memo that was sent out to those
Folks at meta who work on Horizon and
the strategy for 2020 23 was laid out by
VP of horizon Gabriel owl who just
really Drew out what the strategy is for
the team and what the expectations are
for the first half of the year and for
the entirety of the year with that key
goal being a million monthly active
users by the end of 2023.
why is Horizon world so important to
meta I
know and why these young
Newport into Horizon worlds they're
going to be the natives on this new
internet world but why is it so
particularly important to get this
metaverse right I think Horizon worlds
represents the future for meta a few
years ago they changed their name from
Facebook to meta to really highlight
that their intention is to build out
this new kind of internet where
interacting with each other not on
static pages but in Virtual Worlds where
we're all in there simultaneously
interacting and Horizon is their first
stab at building out this metaverse this
may not be the ultimate metaverse that
really you know brings home the bacon
for meta but where we're at now this is
their Flagship product and it's really
important for them that they get this
right that they get some momentum and
that they kind of start to prove out to
investors to users and really to
themselves that this is a vision that
they can really play out but then it
seems important I guess to understand
why it's been so hard for them to keep
users or get users on to Horizon in the
first place right yeah definitely and
there's a variety of reasons for that
you know some of them being that toward
the end of last year the service had
some bugs that really impacted user play
so much so that the entire unit went
into a lockdown where they just did not
put out any new features because they
were focused on fixing all the problems
they've come out of that since then but
beyond bugs another key obstacle for
increasing that that user base is simply
the fact that right now Horizon is
limited to users who already own virtual
reality headsets specifically the quest
headsets made by meta and that's why
another key part of the strategy for
Horizon in 2023 is to release a
so-called 2D version of horizon which
could run on users desktops run on their
phones basically bringing Horizon Beyond
VR and to users who maybe you know can't
get past that 400 buy-in tax to just
even be able to use the product but
rather be able to use it on devices that
they already own sell Zuckerberg
actually addressed this on meta's fourth
quarter earnings call let's take a quick
listen even though most
[Music]
of it run them as the technology
develops
most people are going to experience the
metaverse for the first time on phones
and then start building up their digital
identities across our apps so getting
new users on the platform keeping them
coming back offering new ways to get on
Horizon worlds that seems to be what the
goal is but I want to talk about the
bigger picture Sal because meta has
gotten itself in hot water in the past
for trying to get younger users on its
platforms for the ways younger users
already on some of its social media
platforms interact with it it had this
moment with Instagram where it was going
to have Instagram for children that it's
put on hold so how does it plan to
approach adding young users to Horizon
worlds given that it's had these
problems in the past yeah that's a great
question because this has been a source
of friction for the company in the past
but in the memo we can see that meta is
already thinking about this from the
get-go one of the key goals for the
Horizon team in 2023 is that they also
provide a safe and Equitable experience
and the reason for that being one of the
goals that's outlined in this memo is
because they know that as they go after
younger users it's going to be very
Paramount not just in their own
experience of these users but also in
the perception that these kids are safe
that what's going on in this service is
just something fun and not something
that's going to be detrimental to them
at the same time I think meta is going
to be enjoying a cushion here because
Horizon unlike Instagram unlike Facebook
Horizon it is a social experience but
it's also like a video game and already
teenagers are playing video games
including some rival games that are on
VR headsets so although this has been as
I said a source of friction for the
company in the past when it comes to
Virtual video games it's very common
that teenagers will be on them alright
that was our reporter Salvador Rodriguez
Sal thanks so much for joining us thank
you and that's it for today's Tech news
briefing for more Tech stories check out
our website wsj.com I'm Zoe Thomas for
The Wall Street Journal thanks for
listening
[Music]